more than three billion euros is the
annual total of fraud with EU funds at
present it's up to Member States to try
to get taxpayers money back on Wednesday
a majority of MEP s expressed their
support for a regulation establishing a
European Public Prosecutor's Office some
countries they are doing a fine job in
many other member states they don't so
if the prosecutors in some Member States
don't do anything or very little in this
case is to investigate fraud cases then
we all suffer however some national
parliaments and MEP s strongly oppose
such an office this proposal is a Trojan
horse it would solve nothing
it destroys yet more national
sovereignty but fraud is often committed
across Europe's borders some MEP say a
European public prosecution office would
facilitate and speed up the
investigation the office would be
independent but monitored nonetheless
the staff Nakula to Safari about the
minister's Kadesh nishta over Persia
Greece Ausmus Danelle Argos I know does
most murchison towards the Sun and the
stars of us through control Ian's
several member states are still against
the European public prosecutor's office
but for those in favor it could lead to
a new circle of enhanced cooperation